what's going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 tutorial video uh if
you haven't noticed i am in a new place
just got a new house uh but maybe more
on that later for now let's be talking
about uh python 3. so um in this video
we're going to be talking about input so
if you're familiar with python python27
this is the kind of counterpart to raw
input and the idea here is in kind of
simple gui programs with text-based gui
or graphical user interface programs
sometimes you're going to want to have
some sort of input from a user
so this is going to allow us to have the
user be able to enter some text based
input and we can save it to a variable
so let's go ahead and show an example of
that so we're going to say x equals
input
and then here you don't have to but you
can put some text to kind of notify the
user what you're expecting here so for
example let's say what is your name
we'll make a space here otherwise what's
going to do is going to ask the question
and then the user can type right then in
there and so if you don't add a space at
the end it'll put the type you know
right next uh to that x or the question
mark look kind of weird so a lot of
space
then after that we can do print
um and then something like this hello
comma x and what this will do is print
out hello and then the name the user
input so for example we can go like this
uh we'll run this it says what is your
name well my name is harrison pleased to
meet you
harrison and it says hello harrison
done simple as that
so a real easy tutorial but a pretty
useful thing especially just to get user
input
so if you have any questions or comments
i don't imagine many of you would if you
have any questions or comments leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time